[Music]
i'm losing daylight
this is an expanse of grassland and it
has what i need for a shelter
all this grass that i'm gonna cut down
i'm gonna either turn into my bed or use
for my roof
it's the rainy season which means
you better count on it raining
what
no
wait
oh my gosh
i cannot believe this
[Music]
while i was chopping
i uh chopped up a clump of grass and
under the dirt clod
i just saw this little bit of color
i
would have never thought in my entire
life
i would see
one of these in real life
this is
a blind
worm snake it has a little flickering
tongue because it's a digging machine it
uses this its nose which is one big
large hard scale and it uses it like a
shovel or a wedge and it's able to dig
through the ground and look for its prey
it's a seven striped blind snake a truly
bizarre species
it spends its life deep underground so
sightings are incredibly rare when
you're out here you're up to your knees
in mud
you have funguses and parasites and all
the wounds that get infected
the rain
if you don't love these little things
like this along the way
this place would destroy you
[Music]
here just a few hundred miles from the
equator the light goes out like a
switch i've got to get back to my
shelter
[Music]
you